beautiful intuitive and even better than
before this is what you have all been
waiting Howard in the palm of your hands
as the former VP of design at Apple I'm
here to present you with something that
will blow your mind
Samsung has developed a phone so getting
big it's gonna make your iPhone 5 look
like a piece of [ __ ] yeah that's it I'm
here to present to you with the samsung
galaxy note 3
5.7 inch screen you say yeah 42 inch
screen all up in your face not only has
the screen gotten longer it's gotten
wider phones are supposed to get smaller
and thinner right not with us we want
that [ __ ] to be a burden if you wear
skinny jeans go buy phones
you better gotten ugly for young dick
with the Samsung Galaxy Note 3 we have
improved a stylus to text capability
remember when keyboards came out so we
could type out our thoughts a lot faster
than we could write well here at Samsung
we believe in going backwards in
keyboard we want you to write that [ __ ]
out here's the thing a lot of iPhone
users want to talk about Siri hey we got
s voice watch this s voice what is the
circumference of the earth ie to
anticipate quillian I'm speaking English
I don't s voice please find the closest
rest stop please use healthy like a
plate men find the closest gas station
you ask it but sharing is now easier
than ever because literally you could
share the screen we have deemed this
phone the iPhone killer specifically
because I guess Brandon uses listen I'm
not talking about swipe or
multi-function ability I'm talking about
real-world usage this phone with this 42
inch AMOLED screen can easily be used as
a sword and shield with a stylus in fact
the stylus is a lightsaber Edie can you
come here for a second please
okay and I want you to take this bottle
and balance it on top of your head why
I'm gonna slice the bottle on top your
head with stylus do you let it intern
anymore I don't lose this job you do it
and you can talk to me like that all
right one two I know your alarm on the
size but sooner or later you're going to
realize it'll become an extension of
your body having the phone in the size
of your palm isn't good you want to be
the size of your torso can your iPhone
act as a passenger for your carpool lane
when you're sitting among your friends
and you're on your phone it's annoying
but with the Samsung Galaxy Note 3
everybody can see what you're doing
how'd your password it's impossible the
screen is so huge everybody's gonna see
your [ __ ]
in what you need you need that
fingerprint technology just right nobody
thought
[Music]
and we come hello
yeah one second here's probably easier
if I just text you
[Music]
Sam so bigger is always better
Coria never loose listen I know what
you're thinking you're alarmed by the
size but that's what a lot of people say
when they see a black person's penis
have you seen the camera on the Samsung
Galaxy Note 3 it has a 8200 megapixel
camera
oh then hey 88.2
you know a lot of celebrities come to us
to endorse them with the Samsung Galaxy
Note 3 but here at Samsung we just don't
give to everybody one celebrity that we
had to turn away was the weekend that
ugly [ __ ] let me tell you
something I will give you a phone when
you fix your goddamn hair have you seen
that [ __ ] [ __ ] your hair look like you
got a fight with the forest fire and
lost this is what you need to do you
need to get a hot comb some blue magic
and some holy water and fix that [ __ ] go
huh
Oh